[Musique]
bonjour à tous les éoliennes en question
ce matin dans dimanche en politique
merci d'être fidèle à votre émission de
débat sur france 3 bourgogne et france 3
franche comté
trois invités sont avec moi ce matin je
vous les présente d'abord gérard magnin
vous êtes président de jurassic société
coopérative qui est investi par le biais
du financement participatif dans des
projets d'énergie renouvelable sur
l'ensemble de notre région à vos côtés
myriam normand vous dirigez le sydec du
jura un syndicat mixte qui aide les
collectivités locales notamment dans le
domaine de l'énergie
face à vous michel de broissia président
d'acf c'est un collectif d'associations
de bourgogne franche comté opposé au
parc éolien vous êtes également élu
local maire de champagne sur vingeanne
dans le département de côte-d'or bonjour
à tous les trois merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors vous en avez
l'habitude cette émission c'est aussi la
vôtre vous pouvez l'a commentée sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le mot diez qui
s'affiche dit mme paul bfc comme
dimanche en politique bourgogne franche
comté
je me ferai le relais de certaines de
vos remarques certaines de vos questions
postées sur le site de france 3
bourgogne franche comté depuis le début
de la semaine
tout au long du débat alors madame
messieurs la majorité du conseil
régional affiche une ambition celle de
faire de la bourgogne franche comté une
région à énergie positive c'est-à-dire
une région qui produit plus qu'elle ne
consomme alors il n'y a pas de centrales
nucléaires en bourgogne franche comté
cela implique que tout ou presque
passera par les énergies renouvelables
gérard magnin cela signifie t'il que la
région va se couvrir encore davantage
d'éoliennes que je fais je voudrais déjà
salué les choix qui ont été faits au
niveau de la région pour s'engager
vraiment dans le siècle qui vient parce
que la question aujourd'hui on voit bien
quelle qu'elle est posée en particulier
pour la jeunesse mais pas seulement
c'est un finir avec un monde où en fait
on vivait de l'extraction
du pétrole du charbon du gaz non
renouvelables aussi de l'uranium que on
mettait en danger par les émissions
qu'on faisait ou par aussi des
industries à risque l'avenir de la
planète et que la question qui est posée
aujourd'hui c'est la question d'utiliser
davantage les énergies de flux c'est à
dire les énergies qui passe le soleil
levant et c'est donc la région de
franche-comté s'inscrit dans cette
dynamique au niveau de l'état la
ministre a dit récemment qu'elle allait
faire étudier un scénario 100% énergies
renouvelables alors bien sûr c'est un
objectif c'est pas pour demain
ça prend du temps mais globalement ce
qui à notre agenda pour ce siècle c'est
être capable de produire l'énergie dont
on a besoin
sans faire de fonction sur la nature et
sans émettre de rejet c'est ça la
question principale
myriam normand vous êtes à la tête d'une
structure qui assiste les communes
notamment dans ce domaine de l'énergie
est ce que les collectivités locales les
élus locaux sont prêts à en finir avec
le monde que nous décrivait gérard
magnin et à se lancer avec beaucoup de
projets notamment dans l'éolien alors
effectivement les collectivités les élus
des collectivités sont de plus en plus
sensibles à ces questions et le syndicat
du jour à l'instar des sept autres
syndicats de bourgogne franche comté
sont partenaires de la région de l'état
et de la démo que tout un chacun
notamment à travers une convention
régionale qui marque vraiment
l'engagement de toutes ces
établissements en matière de or non
seulement la production d'énergies
renouvelables mais d'abord de
l'efficacité énergétique
je pense que pour atteindre aussi
l'objectif d'une région énergie positive
il faut pardon réduire les consommations
d'énergie et après sur le je veux dire
le reste des besoins à couvrir ce seront
les énergies renouvelables qu'il et
couvriront et bien évidemment la région
bourgogne franche comté
dans son scénario de région énergie
positive met en évidence que ce sera non
seulement l'éolien mais également le
photovoltaïque et la biomasse donc c'est
un ensemble est un système cohérent qui
progressivement se mettra en route avec
une trajectoire l'horizon 2050 alors
l'éolien fait partie de la stratégie
mais ça veut évidemment dire
deux parcs éoliens oui bien évidemment
mais pas n'importe où n'importe comment
donc un certain nombre d'outils avec
l'appui du conseil régional de l'état et
de l'ademe et je le dirai assez souvent
c'est c'est l'ensemble des acteurs à
tous les niveaux de la région du
département et des structures
territoriales qui se met en marche pour
faire je vais à dire une démarche
beaucoup plus cohérente et beaucoup plus
concertée alors on y reviendra dans le
débat effectivement les collectivités
sont en attente et l son pardon en
attente du fait aussi qu'elles sont
aussi en recherche de ressources
économiques locales puisqu'elles
n'auront pas alors une richesse alors il
ya un élu local sur ce plateau c'est
michel de broissia cet objectif fixé par
la région d'un territoire à énergie
positive vous en pensez quoi vous c'est
un c'est que c'est un objet fantasmer
c'est à dire qu'en fait c'est absolument
irréalisable aujourd'hui les éoliennes
produisent d'une manière intermittente
et donc il ya besoin d'avoir un appui
disons en gros 71% à 2 77 % du temps
pendant pendant lequel les éoliennes ne
fonctionne pas à plein régime et donc en
fin de compte il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
les outils dont qui mériteraient qui
permettrait de faire ça et je doute
qu'on les ait jamais c'est à dire qu' il
faudrait qu'on puisse faire le fameux
power to gas to power et ça enfin moi
j'ai enseigné la thermodynamique je peux
vous dire que à chaque fois il ya un
problème de d'augmentation d'entreprises
cette année de rendement et qu'en fin de
compte au bout de la chaîne on n'a plus
grand-chose
donc si vous voulez on est en train de
transformer quelques on est en train de
faire d'abord on fait une énorme erreur
c'est à dire qu'on fait on poursuit deux
lièvres à la fois un on nous dit il faut
décarbonés la production d'électricité
en france
et ça c'est entièrement l'objet du
sraddt est le sras dette moody's schéma
c'est le schéma régional ces schémas
directeurs on nous dit il faut
décarbonés la production d'énergie en
france la production d'énergie est
décarbonée
donc avant de jeter le bébé avec l'eau
du bain il faudrait peut être réfléchir
est-ce qu'on a les moyens de notre
éthique je crois qu'aujourd'hui on les a
pas du tout est donc en même temps on
nous dit alors on va en même temps se
séparer du nucléaire et en même temps
faire des énergies renouvelables on le
dit en même temps on va avoir 50 % on va
viser 50% de nucléaire et là on nous dit
on va viser 0 donc si vous voulez il ya
une politique qui est totalement
débridée un petit peu face et un
fouillis inextricable quoi voilà alors
j'aimerais vous faire écouter à tous les
trois jeux vous redonner la parole un
évidement emmanuel macron le chef de
l'état il s'est exprimé sur le sujet
cette semaine sur et c'était à pau lors
d'une table ronde sur l'écologie des
territoires il a parlé des éoliennes
on l'écouté on réagit juste après et je
le vis en toute amitié parce que soyons
lucides là aussi la capacité à
développer massivement de l'éolien faut
être lucide elle est réduite
peut-être des porteurs on pourra le
faire
là où il ya du consensus mais le
consensus sur l'éolien est en train de
nettement s'affaiblir dans notre pays il
ya l'éolien offshore qu'on a développé
et relancé très fortement mais de plus
en plus de gens ne veulent plus voir
d'éolien près de chez eux considèrent
que leur paysage est dégradée ne veulent
plus avoir de l'éolien qui s'installe je
regarde les choses comme vous tel qui se
passe du territoire faut pas l'imposer
d'en haut il ne faut pas l'imposer d'en
haut le consensus sur l'éolien est en
train de nettement saf les bières dans
notre pays
gérard magnin c'est une sacrée pierre
dans votre jardin qui lance le chef de
l'état n'en disons que sur ce sujet
comme sur beaucoup d'autres
le chef de l'état semble pas être très
en prise avec les questions tel qu'il se
pose vraiment sur le terrain important
lui c'est ce qu'ils revendiquent en sept
grands prix zahi les territoires qu'il
dit mais il y à il ya deux jours j'étais
encore à chameau loup nous avons acquis
une partie d'un parc éolien avec la
société économie mixte énergies
renouvelables citoyenne notamment
et là il y avait des mères de quatre des
élus de quatre communes qui étaient là
complètement enthousiaste pour faire un
projet chez eux
et l'an dernier on a accueilli en visite
groupée comme ça plus de 1300 personnes
qui sont venues voir ce parc avec l'idée
qu'ils veulent faire les choses chez eux
et cette éolienne qu'on a là
le produit par exemple elle a produit
l'an dernier l'électricité suffisante
pour 2000 ménages c'est-à-dire environ
six à sept mille habitants
et ça c'est pas c'est pareil ça c'est du
désir social mais vous ne contestez pas
ce que dit emmanuel macron quand il dit
le consensus sur lyon vient il
s'affaiblit on accepte de moins en moins
des éoliennes au bout de jardin et qu'il
y ait des minorités agissantes dont
monsieur de broissia et un est un des
porte-parole
mais quand on regarde le nombre qui lie
à nous sur le projet sur lequel nous
sommes
il ya 650 citoyens qui ont investi dans
ce projet 650 citoyens qui sont fiers
c'est du financement participatif je
précise que je vais beaucoup ils sont
pas dans le mode
le to va nous tomber dessus dans le mode
destructif ou dans le mode on s'oppose à
tout ils sont dans un mode
ils sont en accord avec leur siècle ils
sont en accord avec ce qui va se passer
quand dans quelques années peut-être
certains verront d'autres débats là ils
vont dire mais c'est quand même
incroyable qu'en 2020 ces gens se
posaient encore la question s'il fallait
de l'éolien ou s'il en fallait pas parce
que ça va juste être quelque chose
naturelle comme c'est le cas dans
beaucoup d'autres pays nos voisins
allemands ils ont 25% d'éolien
aujourd'hui ils ont 46 % d'énergies
renouvelables dans l'électricité en 2019
alors qu'ils avaient exemple beaucoup de
charges en 2000 et le charbon a baissé
de façon drastique dernier avec une
baisse des émissions de co2 de 7% l'an
dernier ce que la france est
parfaitement incapable de faire michel
de broissia vous êtes une minorité
agissante qui s'oppose à tout comme dit
gérard magnin en fait on peut dire que
le consensus sur l'éolien est en train
de s'affaiblir
tout simplement parce que la population
à une sagesse elle comprend que ça sert
à rien que c'est absurde et donc en fin
de compte j'ai besoin je vais vous
raconter une histoire il ya huit ans
quand j'ai commencé à découvrir le
phénomène éolien je suis allé au congrès
écolo à dijon et là on faisait venir sur
l'ex l'estrade des spécialistes des
psychologues et sociologues ont leur
poser la question qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour améliorer l'acceptabilité de
l'éolien et vous rendez compte déjà il
ya huit ans on se posait cette question
là et ils répondaient tous d'un seul
coeur fait payer les gens voulaient riz
vont devenir doux comme des agneaux
monsieur magnin nous montre la mise en
pratique de cette politique qui n'est
finalement que une manipulation d'une
manipulation de masse walla simulateur
voulait dire je suis un manipulateur
je glisse avec cette politique là est
une manipulation de masse voilà eh bien
je n'en mets donc ce qui les pousse sont
eux mêmes des manipulateurs je pense que
vous avez compris qu'il y avait de très
bonnes affaires à faire pour c'est à
dire que effet glissement pour qui mais
j'ai président bénévole je regarde tous
les administrateurs du président
bénévole
je suis investi comme ont retraité à
fond en tout cas après avoir passé mon
une partie importante de ma vie
professionnelle dans le domaine de
l'énergie
après avoir même été pendant deux ans
administrateur de groupe edf c'est un
sujet que je connais assez bien et si je
m'applique à dedans c'est parce que
précisément comme je les dis je veux
être en accord avec mon siècle pour
préparer une planète qui est vivable
pour les gens je pense que c'est cette
solution d'énergie renouvelables
intermittentes ne fonctionne pas c'est à
dire qu'on veut pas le croire mais si
vous voulez vous pouvez pas éteindre et
rallumer la lumière chaque fois que le
vin s'arrête
hier s'est bien passé à une unique
source de chacun c était une source
d'électricité non plus mentionné mambo
millière d'accord le matin les orientaux
n'est pas le soir il tournait pas non
plus il y avait un espèce damas
d'éoliennes très moche dans une forêt
naturelle et qui ne produisait pas et ça
ça ce procès c'est constamment le cas si
vous voulez au mois de mars l'année
dernière en 2019
les quinze premiers jours du mois il y
avait un vent du tonnerre les quinze
derniers jours il n'est pas devant
qu'est ce qu'on fait les quinze derniers
jours
et ça c'est une réponse il ne peut pas
avoir de réponse là dessus parce que le
power to gas to power il existe pas et
il est loin d'exister avec les besoins
d'énergie que ce après on va donner la
parole je voulais dire quand même que
dans le propos on n'a jamais tous y
compris le président il notamment dans
la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie nationale dit que demain le
nucléaire etc
c'était fini et que c'était les énergies
renouvelables qui prenait la place je
crois que dans la documentation qui
existe on est sur des scénarios
progressiste et qui on va dire
franchissent un certain nombre d'étapes
donc il faut arrêter de dire qu'on passe
de toula à tous
là comme en 1973 on est passé du fossile
office il enfin il faut changer de
discours et avoir un discours comme
positifs comme le dit monsieur manière à
me côté moi je pense aussi qu'il est
important
alors je vous rejoins sur un certain
nombre de propos c'est pas n'importe où
et pas n'importe comment
c'est pour ça aussi que monsieur magna
avec jurassic lé syndicat d'énergie avec
les sem énergie renouvelable qu'il porte
développe des projets en concertation
avec les élus et les acteurs locaux
c'est un vrai changement et sur ce
changement alors c'est vrai on est
encore petit on encore pas une voix qui
est qui porte à plat mais donc du coup
on à la tribune pour en parler
en dix ans on fait différemment en
concertation est ce que il n ya pas
quand même un changement de paradigme
avec c'est quand même une des premières
fois où on entend un chef de l'état
remettre en cause à ce point l'énergie
éolienne
alors on voit ce qui est étonnant c'est
qu'il était à pau pour parler de
l'hydrogène notamment du power to gaz
etc
donc je pense que c'est enfin il avait
je pense un sujet et donc avec l'éolien
on peut produire de l'hydrogène et il
était à pau avec françois bayrou pour
inaugurer je crois des bus à hydrogène
ces examens sont bons par hasard j'étais
à une conférence sur l'hydrogène il ya
quelques jours
donc du coup je le savais dans son
actualité mais il est à plein sur la
question d'électricité d'origine
renouvelable pour produire de
l'hydrogène est également pour faire du
power to gaz donc du coup sûr un certain
nombre de sujets on est aussi en phase
on va peut-être un petit peu aller vers
un compromis et faire des pas pour
essayer d'avancer parce qu'aujourd'hui
ce qu'il est nécessaire de faire c'est
d'avancer et donc il faut aussi non
monsieur les six mois terminés je ne
vous ai pas interrompu donc on est aussi
sur des changements ou les collectivités
reprennent la main sur leur territoire
moi je vous invite aussi sur ces sujets
là à aller vous documenter auprès des
élus qui portent des parcs différents
aléas champmol mais rien n'en on est
quand même très loin des objectifs
affichés en 2012 y avait des schémas
régionaux alors à l'époque
la bourgogne la franche comté n'était
pas fusionner donc mais on prévoyait
2000 100 mégawatts dans l'éolien
aujourd'hui on va voir les chiffres donc
2100 prévu programme et c'était
l'ambition n'est qu'à neuf cent trente
six mégawatts est encore en comptant les
éoliennes en construction c'est 45 % de
l'objectif seulement ça veut dire qu'il
ya de fortes réticences sur le terrain
et que notamment tous les contentieux
ont retardé la construction de départ
que prévu excusez moi mais peut-être que
je pourrais en parler de ça aussi parce
que si vous voulez comme il n'y a pas de
vente dans cette région en fait il ya
deux paramètres qui interviennent dans
la production d'énergie et les griots
lienne il ya le vent et puis il ya la
surface balayée par les pales oui et
donc c'est proportionnel autres à ces
deux paramètres là et donc qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire dans une région où il
n'y a pas de vent parce que la région
bourgogne franche comté il n'y a pas de
vent qu'est ce qu'on fait on est obligé
d'augmenter la taille des éoliennes
si bien que le préfet de haute-saône
nous dit nous dit la times en novembre
2018 la taille normale d'une éolienne
aujourd'hui c'est ses 240 m et dans le
même temps y'a pas de projets
aujourd'hui en sicile et olialia des
projets et cette hauteur là oui 240
domaine et effectivement si vous voulez
dans le même temps à quinze jours
d'intervalle
il ya la dréal qui publie l'atlas éolien
c'est à dire l'atlas paysager delà de la
bourgogne franche comté et sur lequel
l'étude des paysages est fait avec des
éoliennes de 150 m on se fout du monde
franchement justement importe quoi j'en
ai dit on va faire réagir les
internautes ya philippe qui nous a
envoyé une question pourquoi autant
d'implantations éoliennes géantes en
franche comté qui est une région peu
ventées alors qu'il n'y en a pas dans
d'autres régions je vous laisse répondre
gérard magnin vouliez répondre
globalement dire comme une région peu
peuvent hanter là on l'entend beaucoup
c'est bien sûr mais on a une région qui
est moyennement vanter côte regarde la
carte qui existent au niveau national ou
une région moyennement de la - vente on
a le nombre d'heures de fonctionnement
dans cette région elle est moins égal à
l égale à la moyenne nationale
après monsieur de broissia dit il n'y a
pas de vent
mais les gens sont mettre plein les
poches mais savoir si ya pas de vent on
s'en met plein les poches ou bien se met
plein les poches il ya du vent ou bien
n'y a pas de vent et enfin ça peut pas
être les deux à la fois vous donc dans
ces faut absolument faux gentil passant
donc en fait pourquoi il en faut il faut
des grandes machines mais déjà les
technologies ont évolué on est obligé
d'en mettre beaucoup moins parce que là
qui disent il faut pas des industriels
former des plus petites
alors on prend une éolienne qu'on voit
maintenant par exemple de 3 mégawatts si
on dit on en fait 10 de 300 comme on le
faisait il ya 25 ans il faut pas dire
faut 20 ou 30
alors est ce que quelqu'un qui veut pas
une grande qui fait doit faire 200 m il
a envie d'en avoir 20 ou 30 pour la même
chose c'est juste des choses impensables
qui du point de vue économique
d'ailleurs il ya aucune aucune
possibilité que ça se fasse parce que on
raconte toujours des choses comme ça il
en faut pas des grandes mais des petites
ça irait pas non plus donc du coup il en
faut surtout pas aller habiter à côté du
dernier parce que 140 m parce que
derrière le fond d'un moule et estelle
derrière derrière le font aussi de de
monsieur le métier de broc cia qui
pourtant est un ingénieur et donc c'est
que il refuse aussi absolument le fait
qu'on réduise la part du nucléaire en
france
or il faut réduire la part du nucléaire
en france on n'est pas sur un schéma de
l'abandonner
on est sur un schéma de le réduire et
autour de nous ça se passe les suisses
viennent de fermer leurs centrales les
allemands ans ferme une somme aussi
fessenheim la semaine prochaine le mois
prochain
c'est à dire qu on est dans ce processus
là et au niveau mondial on n'a pas plus
de réacteurs aujourd'hui qu'il ya trente
ans donc on est et la france est
incapable de produire de construire son
nouveau réacteur
donc on est là un bout de cycle donc on
doit prendre le relais avec autre chose
tous les problèmes ne sont pas résolus
mais pour des ingénieurs
il ya vraiment de quoi s'éclater en
trouvant des solutions alors à ce propos
du nucléaire je vais vous faire réagir
michel debroux cia jean pierre qui vous
adresse personnellement une question il
vous dit la région bourgogne franche
comté importe 85 % de son énergie
électrique aux autres régions françaises
et à la suisse au prix fort
à une époque où l'on parle de
l'autonomie énergétique comment produire
ce qu'il manque par la construction d'un
op d'un ep air sur la saône fossiles est
au sol effarant effarant de penser que
je suis là j'ai nationalité française et
que en france ont réagi pour produire de
l'énergie réseau parisien
est ce qu'on demande aux départements
alpins de produire le blé pour la france
il se trouve que notre région n'est pas
naturellement adapté pour porter des
centrales type de centrale du caire il
n'est pas adapté pour ça c'est pas et
donc effectivement il ya des régions qui
produisent de l'énergie et des régions
qui produisent du blé des régions qui
produisent du vin
donc si vous ne vous vous dites le
terriblement de l'autonomie énergétique
région par région c'est est une
absurdité c'est scandaleux c'est
scandaleux
comment est ce qu'on peut vivre dans un
pays comme la france et dire des âneries
pareilles et alors je voudrais prendre
ce que disait monsieur manière j'ai je
comprends pas maintenant il parle de 50%
du clair tout à l'heure c'était 100%
renouvelable
en fait on ne sait c'est l'objectif je
parle de rien on comprend rien
l'objectif de 1035 c'est ça qui est
annoncé dans la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie donc objectif
2035 50%
ça veut dire que quand nucléaire baisse
il faut que les renouvelables le monde
pour faire avancer est resté une
émission de co2 identique au là du tout
parce que les renouvelables ne remplace
rien c'est ça le problème qu'on ne
comprend pas moi je peux vous je peux
vous prouver que on a augmenté depuis
les cinq dernières années on a augmenté
de 66%
la puissance installée en éolien et en
solaire
quelle est la conséquence qui a vu
d'après vous sur les émissions de co2
elles ont également augmenté de 47%
ça s'est donnée hervieux donné l'alerté
ou ça ou ça en france montrerez abadonné
à te suis désolé monsieur valliamé je
travaille beaucoup moi aussi et je vais
effectivement vous avez raison je suis
algérien normand sur les conséquences
financières de l'implantation des
éoliennes
évidemment pour les collectivités
locales c'est une ressource nouvelle et
qui peut être attractive
au-delà des enjeux énergétiques oui tout
à fait donc ce sont les collectivités
qui détiennent les richesses locales 1
le vent le soleil la biomasse et donc il
est normal qu'elles aient leur mot à
dire sur ces sur ses ressources et donc
ce soit ces collectivités avec les
acteurs locaux dont dont font partie des
citoyens parce que les citoyens de plus
en plus souhaitent participer à cette
évolution puisse aussi porter des
projets avec du développement qui soit
mesuré
maîtriser et qui fasse partie d'un
consensus et pas d'un 10 ans us et c'est
ça aussi le virage qui a été pris avec
la scène r citoyenne dont le syndicat du
jura est actionnaire majoritaire et du
syndicat d'énergie du doubs est entrée
récemment donc on travaille avec les
élus du jura et du doubs
quand on parle d'un modèle de
développement qui fait appel à
l'ensemble des acteurs pour de la
gouvernance et de la concertation
on change les choses et donc sur la
prise de risques sur les études de
développement c'est la scène qui porte
cette prise de risque et donc du coup
les collectivités ont leur mot à dire
les citoyens les acteurs ont leur mot à
dire et dont tout ce parcours et ses
investissements avec la production
revienne aux territoires et ça c'est une
réaction de bernard sur cette thématique
l'éolien n'est-il pas vous demande-t-il
de façon un peu honteuse l'opium fiscale
des collectivités rurales que l'état et
les régions abandonne avec cette fausse
contrepartie financière
non parce que c'est pas absolument comme
ça que ça marche aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ce sont les opérateurs
privés qui développe des parcs en ayant
les autorisations part obtenu auprès des
collectivités ou des terrains privés et
donc ce sont les développe un enjeu
financier aussi pour les cominois pas se
cacher on connait tous il est un des
budgets non mais c'est pas terminé on
laisse finir madame normand et je vous
donnerai bien évidemment que ce ne sont
pas à l'eau ni l'état ni la région ni
les collectivités qui en bénéficient à
plein aujourd'hui mais plutôt les
entreprises privées donc elles font leur
job leur business simplement ce qu'on
dit aujourd'hui c'est qu'on souhaite que
les collectivités et les acteurs locaux
et les retombées à leur juste mesure
puisque ce sont elles qui détiennent ces
ressources locales naturel c'est
notamment ce à quoi vous attacher au
sein de la sem elle est notamment ce qui
s'est passé sur cham hall avec
l'éolienne de charolles que nous avons
sur l'engin financiers a mis les
ressources locales naturel excusé bois
mort une éolienne se trouve pas ça très
naturel
je suis désolé de vous le dire 1
maintenant j'aimerais vous parler un peu
de santé parce que moi ce matin
excuse-moi jeudi matin
j'ai reçu un mail utilisée je vous
informe que depuis le début de cette
semaine nous sommes fortement gênés par
le bruit des éoliennes nos nuits sont
entrecoupées plusieurs fois notre fils
re commence à avoir des maux de tête
violents qui l'aube il rester à la
maison
nous avons nous aussi des nausées que
mal à la tête régulièrement nous ne
pouvons plus continuer à vivre dans ces
conditions nous sommes épuisés autre
mail de la même personne
je vous envoie ce mail à 5h pour vous
informer que depuis trois heures mon
épouse et moi ne devons plus nous avons
dû quitter notre chambre et nous
réfugier dans la salle de bain je suis
sorti dehors le bruit lloris en voilà ça
c'est des voisins d'éoliennes une
éolienne qui fait 130 mètres de hauteur
2 mégawatts alors merci monsieur
bagnards avec une éolienne de 3
mégawatts ou s'il est à white 240 mètres
de hauteur vous allez faire des heureux
à 500 mètres de distance mais il ya
aussi beaucoup de voisins comme j'ai vu
il ya deux jours a envoyé spécial qui ne
supporte ni le coq de leur voisine nice
et cannes à monsieur les autres je ne
supporte pas l'agriculteur qui avec son
tracteur ça c'est honteux et c'est fait
on trie si vous êtes si vraiment le
bruit lors des vingt sept heures du
matin pour me sens vraiment le bruit est
une préoccupation seront eux il faut il
faudrait que vous vraiment lanciers sur
la protection du bruit des riverains de
roue de routes d'autoroutes d'aéroports
mais rien à voir en brisant les
locations alors je veux dire un mot sur
l'histoire des collectivités locales et
toutes les collectivités locales
cherchent à avoir des activités pour
avoir des revenus fiscaux des activités
commerciales industrielles et ses cent
considèrent que c'est normal et bien
c'est normal aussi pour les activités de
ressources renouvelables
c'est juste une activité comme une autre
qui est de nature à donner aux communes
des revenus comme autrefois les communes
- aujourd'hui avaient des revenus de
leur coût de leurs forêts et aujourd'hui
finalement on peut dire que le vent et
le soleil
eh bien ce sont des ailes nouveaux
éléments de revenus pour les territoires
leurs habitants sur les problèmes
de voisinage je ne vous a pas échappé à
tous les trois je pense que le
gouvernement allemand commençait à
envisager de dédommager les riverains
des éoliennes qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
ça alors ça déjà j'attends de voir la
suite parce que monsieur devra si elle
cite régulièrement que en allemagne
comme si on a le manège comme ça oui
mais c'est aussi si vous aussi vous
l'avez fait en début d'émission sur les
énergies renouvelables et la grande un
exemple mais ce que je vois c'est koné
parti
on est au lien en 2000 en allemagne avec
zéro d'éolien et on a aujourd'hui 25 %
de la production d'électricité en france
nous sommes qu'à 7 % de production
électrique mais il semble que le vent si
je peux me permettre est en train de
tourner en allemagne leveaux en train de
tourner on est on est arrivé nimbé toute
façon que la question va là où une
question qui se pose c'est la question
de la maîtrise locale des projets comme
ça a été dit tout à l'heure par an d'un
normand et dans des projets qui qui
viennent d'ailleurs et où le niveau
local ne pas impliquer les citoyens
c'est pas très bien et nous on essaie de
faire en sorte que ce soit bien parce
que précisément il ya une application
locale 10 secondes pour conclure bah
écoute et l'association ac b fc elle
demande une distance de précaution vos
habitations de 10 fois la hauteur des
éoliennes
elle demande le retour au code de la
santé publique c'est vraiment trop
triste
merci à tous les trois on vous
réconciliera pas sur cette question en
tout cas j'ai bien compris tout de suite
votre flash d'information en région et
puis ensuite la suite de dimanche en
politique francis letellier reçoit
marine le pen bon dimanche à tous
[Musique]